why
are beauty standards so diverse between
cultures is it natural genetics or
marketing
for example thin european women versus
larger more curvy hips and behinds being
the rage in america
um um again lots lots of places to go
here yeah there's there's a lot of
everything in the answer to this
question a
there are certain things that are um
um trying to come up with objective
language but
there's certain things that are more
beautiful than other things in ab in
objective
terms um there are other things which
are arbitrary
and are hallmarks of um
you know membership and you know lots of
stuff that is processed
you know you would expect men and women
to process things that are proxies for
stuff that matters right and so like
across cultures
particular ways to hip ratios and women
um
regardless of whether or not the
preference is for a thinner purse of
thinner women or
larger women still the hip the waist to
hip ratio
preferences are more or less stable um
which
is suggestive of an interest totally
unconscious presumably
in fertility right um breast
too although i think there's a
persistent paradox with this one
which is to a point larger breasts are
something that you would expect
men to be interested in because they are
a proxy for
the amount of resource necessary to
produce a baby which is not a small
amount of resource which doesn't mean
that the resources in the breast go into
the baby but it means that a woman
whose breasts are large or larger than
some
threshold has those resources on board
but but not i mean that's that's only
true when you're actually
actively breastfeeding nope i would say
not
i would say i don't there's no evidence
that size of breasts outside of
uh having a baby at the breast is
predictive of how much milk you can
produce
i think there no no it's not a question
of how much milk you can produce it's a
question of how much excess resource so
for those who are okay so um a
human females are the only mammals in
which breast tissue
is enlarged when not lactating so that's
a fascinating and important fact
um but anyway therefore clearly sexually
selected right therefore clearly
sexually selected
it is a an advertisement it is an
advertisement of the presence of
resources but what i don't quite get
and i don't get it either as you know a
red-blooded male
or as a scientist is why
above some threshold there seems to be
this obsession with bigger is better
right that doesn't add up right to the
extent that a woman
has in some way physiologically
demonstrated the resources to produce a
baby
that would seem to be like a check box
rather than you know the bigger the
better so i don't understand why
that seems to be a a priority that
many men seem to uh well this this will
end up being a cultural difference and
it is i mean it is a bit peacocky
right um that you know the the big showy
tna versus uh a more slender aesthetic
uh in some cultures is is a cultural
difference
some of which is describable to
differences in resources
not so easily done in the modern era
between europe and north america right
but in terms of cultures in which there
are regular boom bust cycles of food
availability
preferences for um you know finding
beauty in more heavyset
you know both women and men uh would
have been effectively
a potential um way
to prevent famine not personal famine
like starvation rather
well i sort of think it's a like a tin
bergen
uh phony egg phenomenon so tim bergen
who was one of the early
brilliant ethologists i think he was
actually richard dawkins advisor
um he uh
did an experiment in which there was a
preference in gulls which was his study
organism
for larger eggs and what he showed was
that there was actually no upper limit
right the bigger the egg didn't make any
difference absurd
non-egg-like phony eggs were still
preferred in some way
even when anatomically impossible given
the size of the bird
right and so i guess what i'm it's it's
a little bit like people's uh
affinity for sugar and things it's like
there was no reason to set a limit on
how much sugar to
you know to to avoid because the
presence of arbitrarily large amounts of
sugar and the environment just isn't a
thing until
industrialization um so i think it might
be something
something like that i have run into
something recently which we might want
to track down
if you haven't maybe maybe you and i
have talked about it but
there is this belief that beauty
standards have changed radically
in the west and that is inferred from
rubenesque
uh paintings in which
uh women with a great deal of what
once have been called pulchritude um
uh were painted but the recent evidence
suggests
actually that this may have to do with
the models who were available to the
painters not
the preferences um and so that in fact
this may have been misinterpreted
so anyway oh it's interesting i haven't
heard that for a topic for another time